Harley Quinn is practically the antiheroic
queen of the DC Universe, but the one place
you aren't going to find her is Zack Snyder's
Justice League.
Even at four hours in length, the film apparently
didn't have room for Margot Robbie's Harley
amongst the story of the greatest heroes on
Earth battling Steppenwolf from remaking Earth
in Apokolips' image.
The outcome of the Justice League Snyder Cut
is similar to that of the theatrical version
that was released in 2017.
However, it's a lot clearer in the director's
cut that Darkseid is coming, and we're left
with one final scene in which Batman and his
crew of misfits wander around the post-apocalyptic
hellscape Batman has a vision of.
It's here, in the premonition of the Knightmare
reality, where Batman has a brief conversation
with the Joker.
However, Joker's presence in the Snyder Cut
does lead to some questions — the most immediately
pressing of which regards Harley Quinn.
If Joker's around, then where's his beloved
partner in crime?
In a key piece of dialogue in Zack Snyder's
Justice League, Harley's fate is revealed.
"Isn't that right, Batman?"
In the film, Batman has another vision of
the Knightmare reality that seems to be what's
destined to happen when Darkseid comes to
Earth.
This sequence shows Batman agreeing to a truce
with the Clown Prince of Crime; however, while
they don't go at each other's throats in the
moment, it's clear there's still a lot of
animosity between the two, especially when
Joker brings up the Dark Knight's greatest
failing: allowing his sidekick Robin to die.
Batman throws this statement back at his arch-nemesis
by mentioning how Harley Quinn died in his
arms.
He also tells Joker that Harley made him promise
that when he finally killed her ex-boyfriend,
he had to do it slowly.
Batman tells Joker,
"She begged me, with her last breath, that
when I killed you — and make no mistake,
I will f---ing kill you — I do it slow.
And I'm gonna honor that promise."
It's an intense moment, and the magnitude
isn't lost on Joker, who quivers after the
threat.
No more information is given outside of that,
such as what caused Harley Quinn to die, but
one thing is abundantly clear: She and Joker
definitely probably didn't make up before
her death.
While it seems unlikely at this point that
Justice League 2 will come to fruition, especially
with Snyder at the helm, we at least know
that Harley probably won't have a role within
the Knightmare timeline if the project does
happen someday.
"That wasn't me."
So, is there a chance we could actually see
this heartbreaking death scene come up in
a future DCEU film that isn't a Justice League
sequel?
Don't hold your breath.
Outside of a role in the upcoming Flash movie,
it's looking more and more unlikely that Affleck
will be the mainline Dark Knight going forward
— especially given the fact that Batman's
getting a solo movie that stars Robert Pattinson
as a younger Bruce Wayne and doesn't seem
to have anything to do with Snyder's films.
Despite all of the shaky continuity within
the DCEU, Robbie's Harley Quinn appears as
though she'll continue to be a force in the
franchise going ahead.
In just a few months, she'll appear in The
Suicide Squad, which debuts in theaters and
on HBO Max on August 6, 2021.
Beyond that upcoming movie, it's unclear what
Harley Quinn's cinematic future could entail.
The Suicide Squad writer-director James Gunn
teased on Instagram a while back that he and
Robbie discussed working together in the future.
One would assume if The Suicide Squad is well-received,
a follow-up would be in the cards, with Robbie
returning to the cast.
There's also the possibility of a sequel to
Birds of Prey as well as a solo Harley Quinn
movie.
There's a lot of room for growth with the
antiheroine, and DC probably isn't going to
kill her off any time soon just to make good
on a scene that exists only in a director's
cut version of a film.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
comic book heroes and villains are coming
soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.